[Applaudissements]
prendre le large
littéralement vous espériez peut-être ce
soir commencer par françois gabart où
armel le cléac'h en fait vous avez
commencé avec un cheminot de 38 ans
marié 3 enfants parisiens depuis 12 ans
mon truc à moi c'est les voyages je
traversais une centaine de pays j'ai
commencé par le sac à dos j'ai commencé
par le vélo j'ai continué en moto en
camping car
mais voilà aucune expérience de maire au
delà de quelques stages de hobie cat et
d'optimiste quand j'étais gamin et à
côté de ça un projet complètement barré
complètement fou traverser l'océan
pacifique avec ma femme et mes trois
enfants en bas âge sur mon voilier sur
son catamaran ce soir j'aimerais
partager avec vous cette question toute
simple c'est comment est ce que réalise
un projet aussi fou chouette il comment
sa pose plein de questions
la première c'est que d'abord vous
traverser un océan si vous prenez une
appli google earth et que vous tournez
le côté bleu de la planète
vous avez en un désert n'a à peu près
qu'il fait à peu près 13 mille milles
nautiques 20 milles kilomètres avec la
plus grande partie des océans sans
aucune sans aucune terres immergées
là c'est entre les îles galapagos les
îles marquises cette traversée elle fait
3000 milles nautiques
c'est plus grand que la transatlantique
entre les et du cap vert et la
martinique
alors quand on réalise quand on réunit à
moi et ma famille sans expérience de
voile et cette traversée ça donne un
projet fou comment est-ce qu'on passe du
boulevard diderot à paris à la deuxième
barre de flèche demi à l'ong en un an
première question c'est pourquoi
pourquoi au fond réalise un projet comme
celui là
mais d'abord si vous êtes un voyageur
passionné vous voulez visiter cette
partie bleue de la planète
vous n'avez pas le choix il faut lire et
en bateau l'atoll de palmerston les îles
marquises vous n'avez pas le choix il
faut y aller en bateau
et puis ça corresponde à une période de
ma vie où ma fille avait deux mois elle
venait de naître mon aîné avait avait 7
ans et j'avais simplement envie de
passer avec ma femme du temps de qualité
avec des enfants à un âge où c'est
important de passer du temps avec leurs
parents et quand je me replonge sur ces
18 mois placé dans l'hémisphère sud
je trouve que l'on en fait ça a été un
phare dans ma vie qui m'a permis de
mieux me comprendre
moi ma famille mes enfants mais aussi le
monde dans lesquels dans lequel je vis
alors quelle que soit la raison un jour
l'idée elle arrive et vous tombe dessus
elle commence à vous obséder et puis
vous avez deux choix au fond soit vous
dit allez on laisse tomber on passe à
autre chose et on va préparer les
vacances de cet été
soit vous dit allez chiche en hiver et
comment est ce que en un an de l'idée
autour d'un sandwich à la corde à la
cafet vous vous retrouvez à passer la
première écluse du canal de panama
quand je me repose sur cette année de
préparation
ça nous a pris un an vraiment entre la
décision et le billet d'avion je reviens
trois messages importants
le premier c'est que quand vous avez un
projet fou les gens vont vous prendre
pour des fous et ben en fait il faut
vivre avec
c'est à dire que dans le milieu de la
mer on dit souvent il ya les vivants les
morts et ceux qui vont sur la mer
c'est très vrai c'est à dire que quand
vous parlez de leurs projets de mer vous
ne retrouvez déco qu'auprès des quelques
rares personnes qui ont déjà fait une
traversée ou vécu sur un bateau la
deuxième leçon c'est que un projet fou
c'est un projet qui par essence comporte
des risques et on pourrait se dire le
risque c'est l'apanage des têtes brûlées
ma femme et bancaires d'affaires et moi
je suis un ancien auditeur
alors du coup des formations
professionnelles on a pris le risque
de manière extrêmement professionnelle
le risque ça s'évalue ça se maîtrise et
ensuite la partie résiduelle elle se
confronte à votre appréciation qui est
tout à fait personnel prenez le risque
de mer le plus évidente
comment est ce que quand on sait pas
naviguer on va gérer une tempête en
plein milieu des 40e rugissants
la première chose c'est que ce truc
apprendre à naviguer
il ya des bonnes écoles de voile en
france et deuxième chose est pas obligé
de partir tout de suite sur votre bateau
larguer les amarres et partir tous
debout vous pouvez aussi partir par
exemple les trois premiers mois avec un
propriétaire de bateau skippers
chevronnés qui voudraient partager
l'utilisation son bateau et ensuite vous
laisser en confiance en bateau et vous
faites la même chose surtout les risques
le risque médical risques financiers
le risque sur votre propre carrière
méthodologie dernière leçon c'est la
chance on se dit un gars qui a traversé
le pacifique c'est comme un gars qui a
gagné au loto c'est once in a lifetime
moi je pense qu'au contraire la chance
et une série d'opportunités qui
s'offrent à vous et je compare souvent
la vie à une session de surf dans une
eau glacée
soit vous restez les fesses dans l'eau
froide à vous plaît et à laisser passer
les vagues les unes après les autres
soit un moment donné vous mettez
débouche sur votre planche et vous allez
voir votre destin alors ça y est on est
parti et on se trouve au milieu du
pacifique
qu'est ce qu'on vit j'aimerais en
quelques minutes partager avec vous
cette expérience que j'ai pu vivre en
ville no 17 20 mille kilomètres qui
commence au canal de panama avec deux
grandes traversées d'abord face au vent
jusqu'aux îles galapagos ensuite porté
par les alizés cette longue traversée
jusqu'aux îles marquises ça nous a pris
16 jours et une série d'archipels qui
aussi surprenant que ça puisse être sont
extrêmement différents les uns des
autres
on s'était dit finalement ça m de la
plage et ça va être très beau mais ça va
être un peu toujours pareil ben non
shaquille chaque plage
chaque clic chaque mouillage est
complètement différent avec sa faune sa
flore etc
et puis on finit par une autre grande
traversée celle de la nouvelle colonie
et la nouvelle-zélande
là aussi souvent redouté parce que face
au vent et
là on a effectivement passé les
quarantièmes rugissants et ce projet qui
était complètement fou est devenu notre
quotidien et le quotidien c'est comme à
paris en fait c'est fait de petits
bonheurs de grands bonheurs aussi et de
petites galères et des fois aussi de
grosses grosses galères le p'tit bonheur
c'était des rituels tout simplement le
soir avec le coucher du soleil prendre
systématiquement l'apéritif à 18h30 et
puis comme on vit avec le rythme du
soleil un des petits bonheurs que
j'avais c'était me pendant mon quart
voir mon fils qui n'arrive pas très bien
à dormir se réveiller et venir voir le
lever du soleil et voir les dernières
lueurs delà de la croix du sud avec le
lever du soleil
et puis bien entendu il ya eu d énorme
bonheur je rends partager avec vous ont
navigué depuis 16 jours pour arriver aux
îles marquises on arrive de nuit à la bd
vierge à fatu hiva et le soleil se lève
et voilà spectacle qu'on avait devant
nous ça a été un des plus grands
souvenirs de ma vie parce que je pense
que très objectivement c'est un des plus
beaux endroits sur la terre et vous
passez d'une situation où vous êtes en
autonomie totale avoir que du bleu tout
le temps pendant 16 jours un endroit ou
à terre vous avez des gens qui sont
extrêmement accueillants qui aurifère
content d'avoir de la visite avec des
fruits à profusion et énormément de
bonheur autre grand bonheur on est aussi
sur la toile de palmerston aux îles cook
et là on est en train de profiter d'une
session de snorkeling remonte à bord et
pour faire les devoirs avec les enfants
et l'agent me dis parfois regarde qu'est
ce qu'il ya c'était tout simplement deux
baleines qui venaient avec leurs
baleineaux nager à 10 mètres du bateau
parce que dans l'hémisphère sud elles
n'ont pas l'habitude d'en voir et qu'ils
sont plutôt curieuse grand moment de
bonheur
alors on est à cergy pour toi je vais
vous épargner le slide show parce que
bon un soir de mai voilà il a lui aussi
des petites galères bien entendu une
autre anecdote intéressante pendant
vingt minutes je mouline pour amener une
superbe dorade coryphène au large de la
nouvelle zélande et en fait c'est un
requin mako un peu hargneux et
totalement avant jab donc je vous
rajoute vous rassure il a fini il a fini
à la mer dans son élément naturel et
puis on a eu aussi des grosses grosses
galères un soir aux îles fidji au
mouillage avec une dizaine de bateaux
autour de nous et imaginer une dizaine
de patates de corail derrière nous
le vent se met à souffler 20 noeuds 39
49 et là le bateau commence à reculer et
le problème c'est que j'avais plus
beaucoup d'essence dans les deux moteurs
et pendant 24 heures j'ai dû gérer on à
remouillé trois fois de suite leur encre
pour pas dérapé et vous avez entre les
mains un bateau qui coûte plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'euros donc pas
de risques directement pour notre vie
mais beaucoup beaucoup de stress
alors comment on revient d'un projet
comme celui-là on veut pas aborder la
question de prendre le large
littéralement sans aborder la question
du retour à la côte on nous a souvent
dit alors tu as trop dur de reprendre le
métro
comment ça se passe les enfants la
cantine tout ça en fait la réponse se
trouvait dans le projet lui-même
nous on n'est pas parti pour tout
plaquer on ne fuyait pas quelque chose
qui nous convenait pas dans notre vie en
fait on est parti parce qu'on avait
envie de grandir de vivre quelque chose
et de revenir chez nous et c'est
exactement ce qu'on a fait et on est
revenus grandi et n'allez pas croire que
professionnellement cette expérience
peut vous pénaliser quand je suis revenu
j'ai été nommé chef de projet pour le
déménagement du siège de la sncf entre
paris et saint denis et le directeur de
l'immobilier qui était mon patron m'a
fait cette confidence
quelques mois après m'avoir recruté il
m'a dit benoît un mec je me suis quand
je t'ai recruter un type qui est capable
de faire traverser l'océan pacifique à
sa famille sans savoir naviguer de bien
être capable de faire traverser le
boulevard périphérique à quelques
milliers de cheminots
c'est mon expérience c'est l'excellence
de ma famille celle qu'on a vécu
ensemble il ya quatre ans et vous je
suis sûr que là ce soir dans votre tête
il ya un projet une idée qui germe
peut-être depuis quelques mois peut-être
quelques années et autant de raisons de
ne pas vouloir y aller
qu'est ce que vous attendez bien aller
au bout de ses rêves
c'est tout ce fou
[Applaudissements]